The joe rogan experience.
Let's take like it's just one small
example of like how my belief system
works about this.
Uh,
there's this one thing called the
accumulation mindset.
I call it,
uh,
I work online with people on fat loss
programs and when you really look at
their lifestyle,
their into the z accumulation mode of
just buying an amassing all of this
stuff.
I've been in some people's homes where
the shelves are just littered with stuff
they never use or don't need.
You know,
they,
they just have so much stuff.
The attic is full of stuff,
the garage is full of stuff,
but they keep buying more and more
adding,
adding.
The body's reflect this type of belief
system and for sure they're adding more
cells under their body.
Just indulge it,
you know?
And then they find themselves over
eating,
eating more than their fair share of the
natural resources of the universe.
Taking more n a,
I mean it's just like this whole belief
system in accumulation.
Like I need to add,
I need to add is all subconscious.
Of course,
no one goes into it.
You know,
how much do you sleep?
Maybe now that I'm,
I'm doing all this crazy stuff.
Uh,
three hours.
Three.
It was a lot.
Wow.
What do you normally sleep if you
weren't doing that?
If I'm lucky.
Wow.
Four hours.
Maybe we'll you're juiced up on nicotine
dollars,
Huh?
No,
it has to do with,
I have to worry of the editing.
Like,
you know,
like I have to do the notes at night so
that they can edit during the day.
And then I go in at night and then now
like with all these,
like with radio as you know,
like radio and all that stuff,
it's like this is a weird schedule.
It's all of that.
And then doing shows at night,
because I never stopped doing shows.
Right,
of course.
But I meant like,
when you're not doing this and you said
five hours,
five hours maybe.
Is that because you're all juiced up
with nicotine all the time?
I think cause I'm old and my prostate
tells me it's time to get up.
I take a leak five hours and you're
good.
Um,
if I'm lucky,
you know,
get some palm palm juice.
Have you tried some of those pills that
help?
What is this doctor?
Oz Guinness.
It's shit.
It's like we were just watching heavy
metal and there's like a Caribou carcass
here.
It's like,
have you ever thought of like who gives
a shit?
It's part of getting old guys.
Get used to it.
Joe,
you're old enough to start now and not
have any probably any problems from
smoking.
You'll tried out for a year.
You would never saw anybody who was an
athlete in their youth or like stole is
involved in athletics?
Like smoking is a no,
my cardio was very important to me.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I understand that.
You know,
never fuck around with that,
but I'd get it.
I do love like,
uh,
you know,
smokers do like,
I'm just talking about like my dad and
his friends,
like they would have amazing like
smokers superpowers where it's like,
no,
they couldn't do anything.
But like if there was like something
like,
you know,
hey,
I need your help.
What happened?
My car fell in a ditch and like they
would just come out with a cigarette in
the mouth and like lift up the,
I was like,
man,
that's so cool.
You know there's a diaper that they're
selling now.
Totally.
I'm Tony Terra Gousha frozen.
A lot of times a menu you fucking get a
little drippage is a Tampon were at the
front of your diaper
cause you Dick League man pawn and
they're trying to sell it as like a
normal thing.
I mean was this guy with this swollen
inflated,
got it filled with undigested food and
feces that has had been pushed out yet?
Yes.
Fat that permeates all the different
layers of his skin and cause he,
she's not a muscle left under that and
I'll,
muscles are all gone.
I'm here to tell you that my dick ain't
broken.
I mean Italian,
my Dick's leak and trust me just wear a
tampon.
Keeping them fucking meatball subs.
The bullish Fargo meatballs,
they got me balls and saw they got
monique got,
they got good.
The good peppers they put on the top day
society.
Oh bless his soul.
God bless her.
She died of a heart attack at 51 she
weighed 300 pounds.
He's the guy driving that truck,
that beep dot.
Mcgary fucking God.
I got my fucking peppers.
She had got my meatballs.
I know when I walk my the fat on my feet
spills over the outside of my sneakers.
I like that.
That looks like a little waterfalls.
Dig into my heel.
Who I stepped down just
rolls over.
I like,
I liked the waddle cause my fucking
guns,
my gun sticking out.
My legs can't stay.
So the way the back of my head looks to
dog the hot dog roll.
Look,
I look fat sausages that are grown out
of the base of my skull.
It looks like a mix.
You're hungry for the fucking,
the either the fucking nice to so source
each show my face.
You see a wrinkle in my face.
You see any spider marks by my eyes?
Fuck no,
because the flesh is pushing out against
the skin all the time.
It's pulled tight.
It makes me look young and vibrant.
Look at my Chin's tight.
All of them died.
Tell him,
tell him the story about how,
how you wrote your training with our
lasky after training where he's,
he goes,
come here.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
Andre Arlovski and I used to train
together,
uh,
Jackson's camp and I was getting ready
for a fight this over shoot almost four
years ago.
The two fighters that I,
when I first got into the game that I
admired and loved where Mirko Cro,
cop and Andrea are Laski by two very
favorites.
That's who I wanted to be like.
So I walked in the gym and it was our
lost keys first day at Jackson's too.
And uh,
you know,
when you seen a guy in TV fighting all
the time,
then you run into me like,
damn,
all right.
So I see him like,
Oh shit,
this under lawsky.
So then like I shop her last year in the
ring,
first day spine,
right,
fresh off the plane and we're sparring
with them.
So me and him are gone and it's,
it's a close round.
He's a Badass,
right?
I'm are going back and forth.
People would literally stop and watch a
spar were just these dog rounds back and
forth,
five rounds in a row.
Then later that night we grapple and
then the next morning I drink coffee
every morning.
Right.
Or drinking coffee,
not this horrible coffee breath,
breath smell like pure coffee,
shit breath.
Right.
And I'd go up to Andre and he's,
he's not very warm person at all.
Nope,
not at all.
Is that very Belarus rush in where it's
going to take a while to be his friend?
I can tell and I'm trying to break these
barriers,
man.
I don't know.
Hey Brah just wanna let you know,
man.
I got the coffee breath and he,
uh,
he didn't say a word to me the night
before training goes,
it's okay.
It's okay.
Much better than yesterday.
Yesterday.
Shit.
I go,
what?
He goes yesterday,
breast smelled like Shit.
Oh cool man.
Cool.
And then just went about our business.
That was really the only words he ever
said to me,
man.
We trained together for a while.
It wasn't even like from,
what about when you were kicking,
when you had your kick his body?
Yeah.
And then we'll get done a train.
I've never done this.
He goes,
ah,
I'm trying to do my best Russian accent
it,
you guys are pretty much terrible.
That's horrible.
Right?
Okay.
Sorry,
I'm not from Russia.
He goes up,
he goes,
put your hands on top of your head like
this.
And I'm like,
what are we doing?
And we just got done sparring.
I'm exhausted,
right?
I put my hands up and he just goes,
braced herself and starts wailing at my
body.
Why?
With kicks punches Waylon is this,
this make you tough?
My okay.
And I'm like,
oh,
I'll try to be tough though.
Cause he's my hair all like,
oh,
okay.
Oh Wow.
And then he goes,
my turn,
you do it to me.
And I'm like,
dude,
he goes,
no,
you hit like girl hit.
And I'm fucking trying,
man.
Trying to hurt this guy.
Nothing.
And that was my experience with Andre
Arlovski.
Okay.